Robert Patito is an attorney and an
activist and he joins us tonight Robert
thank you for coming on so if that's
darker progressive if progressive
activists have a right to intimidate and
scream at people they disagree with
politically in public places in
restaurants for example or outside their
homes what are the boundaries of that I
mean do you have a right to show up at
someone's kids soccer game and scream at
the parents do you have a right to show
up at the person's church that their
parents funeral I mean what are the
boundaries now in this new activism on
the left well Tucker one thing I think
is important he started off this segment
by talking about the First Amendment
rights in freedom of speech what Maxine
Waters said to her supporters was to
exercise their freedom of speech so if
you see somebody who is in power
confront them speak to them about the
issues we're in a swamp territory in DC
right now where individuals only listen
to lobbyists into special interest
groups if the only time you get to speak
to elected officials is when they're in
public then by all means don't commit
violence don't commit anything that will
harm the individual but let them know
how you feel people have the right to
exercise their First Amendment rights
and I'm actually it's it's a little
stunning for me to take a lecture about
the First Amendment from anyone on the
left who've been working overtime for
the past couple of years to curtail our
First Amendment rights who invented this
fake category of hate speech etc but
leaving that aside this is not a debate
about anyone's right to speak it's a
debate about whether it's appropriate to
scream at people in public and to force
them out of for example restaurants this
is not an attempt to win them over or to
show them another side of the issue it's
an effort to intimidate them you can't
read it any other way you're not telling
me they're trying to inform Sarah
Huckabee Sanders they were punishing her
look Tucker the entire point is that
because these members of the
administration don't talk to the
American people they don't have regular
press briefings they don't go out and
have town hall meetings this is the only
time the individuals have the
opportunity to speak with them the show
yesterday wait wait hold on this comes
between yesterday they don't give press
briefing look we hear a lot from the
administration we hear a lot from its
opponents I welcome that almost uniquely
on television I like debates
I'm glad that you are here we disagree I
think we should have a converse
you do not have the right to scream at
me in front of my children in a
restaurants around my house and the
weekend where my kids are home come to
my church go to their soccer games go to
my parents funerals do you see the
difference between having a debate over
the issues in intimidating people in the
public's face
well let's understand that the entirety
of this issue started with a lack of
messaging but on the part of the
administration by not explaining what
the detention policy is by not
explaining what exactly is happening to
these children if the president and the
administration who want to have a
conversation about this do like other
administrations have done go do town
halls around the country speak to voters
and let the people express their
feelings to the administration
understand what public opinion is don't
simply hide behind the walls of power
and nobody's going to use soccer games
or field job they're saying actually in
public well those are public spaces and
I guess the point I'm making is once you
start describing people you disagree
with politically as Nazis as the worst
category of almost non human beings you
are almost by definition encouraging
first of all you're you're closing out
any possibility of agreement or
compromise and you're basically saying
hurt them I mean what do you do -
honestly I'm being sincere with you what
do you do - what not see if you really
thought Nazis were taking over the
country you know what I would do I would
consider force I don't want to be
governed by Nazis so that's what we
don't talk that look is it by its
definition encourages violence right but
no Tucker let's understand the during
the Obama administration he was accused
of ever being everything from a Muslim
sleeper cell to not an American citizen
this is what happens Joe washe was
yelled at you lie during the
presidential address the discourse that
he have in this nation has become
caustic somebody has to fix the issue
but right now we have an administration
that refuses to speak to the American
people it's difficult to get in there
okay again it's not my job to flag for
the White House but holy smokes he just
did an hour long live event yes she's
doing an hour long live event tomorrow I
mean they speak a lot that's not really
the issue the issue is whether you have
a right to take political differences
and turn them into some kind of mob
retaliation against the people you
disagree can we just agree on this
maybe the left should stop calling
people Nazis maybe that's too far
maybe that is setting the table for
something awful can we agree on that or
is it okay to like in peak of Adolf
Hitler I mean for real
look Tucker we can agree on that but can
also the right not support the Charlotte
field actual Nazis who are walking
around what swastikas
that's what foam anybody who would
support it okay look I've never met
anybody that I mean any side gram
intentions okay but it's one thing to
say of someone who is espousing I guess
Nazi views your Nazi but to say about
someone who disagrees with you on
immigration policy you are a nazi what
you're saying is I don't need to win you
over debate you what I need to do is
destroy you and that's what the left
just saying isn't it I think what
happens is when you do not condemn we do
not condemn people like David Duke we do
not condemn the neo-nazis in
Charlottesville then you get your issues
conflated with them well as I said
there's a difference between doing an
hour-long speech to people and having a
town hall where you speak with people
and get their input get their side of
the conversation helps people yeah okay
Robert thank you